hablamos de salud en directo América de
France 24 ya está conmigo en el estudio
Marina sardina Marina bienvenida buena
mañana de miércoles vamos a iniciar con
una nueva investigación piloto córneas
creadas a partir de colágeno de cerdo
devuelven la visión a 20 personas que
eran ciegas o tenían problemas graves de
visión antes de participar en este
estudio Marina de qué se trata esta
investigación publicada en la revista
científica nature Brian tology bueno
Raúl buenos días es sin duda una gran
avance para la ciencia y para las
personas que padecen ceguera corneal que
se estima que al menos 12,7 millones de
personas en todo el mundo padecen esta
enfermedad los participantes en el
estudio clínico padecían queratocono una
afectación en la que la capa externa
protectora del ojo una especie de
membrana se adelgaza y sobresale
progresivamente impidiendo que la luz
llegue al fondo del ojo la única forma
de recuperar la visión es a través de un
trasplante de córnea de un donante
humano pero solo uno de cada 70
clientes reciben este trasplante por
ello un grupo de investigadores suecos
desarrollaron córneas que como decimos
Es la capa transparente más externa del
ojo y se compone de proteína de colágeno
Entonces ellos crearon estas córneas a
partir de colágeno de piel de cerdo un
tejido corneal creado por
bioingeniería 14 de los pacientes
estaban ciegos antes de recibir el
implante pero después de dos años del
procedimiento habían recuperado parte o
la totalidad de su visión los
trasplantes de córneas están atravesados
por grandes inequidades socioeconómicas
Raúl no son fácil fáciles de acceder la
mayoría de personas que necesitan esto
se encuentran en países empobrecidos o
de renta media con mayores limitaciones
para el tratamiento debido a la falta de
infraestructura adecuada para el
almacenamiento de las córneas que deben
usarse en menos de dos semanas sin
embargo estas membranas de colágeno de
cerdo se pueden almacenar por hasta dos
años
lo que señala el estudio
para hacer frente a estas limitaciones
diseñamos mediante bioingeniería un
dispositivo médico implantable libre de
células como sustituto del tejido del
estroma corneal humano como materia
prima utilizamos colágeno natural tipo 1
principal proteína de la córnea humana
para un suministro abundante Pero
sostenible y rentable del colágeno
utilizamos colágeno de calidad médica
procedente de la piel porcina un
subproducto purificado de la industria
alimentaria que ya se utiliza en
dispositivos médicos aprobados por la
fda para la cirugía de glaucoma Y cómo
vendaje para heridas
según los autores del estudio la técnica
empleada durante la cirugía también es
menos invasiva y abarataría Los costos
aportando un mayor un mayor acceso a las
personas que lo necesitan por ahora el
equipo espero al replicar los resultados
en un estudio más amplio con 100
pacientes y trabajar en la aprobación de
los organismos reguladores Raúl
cambiamos de información Marina porque
el lunes el que pasó Se cumplió un año
desde la toma talibán de kabul la
capital de Afganistán además de un
retroceso en derechos humanos también se
agravó por supuesto las precarias
condiciones de salud en ese país sí y
así lo viene alertando la OMS la
Organización Mundial de la Salud desde
hace tiempo la situación sanitaria en
Afganistán es muy crítica y en
septiembre de 2021 por ejemplo un mes
después de que los talibanes hicieran
con el país solo el 17% de las
instalaciones médicas estaban en
funcionamiento se estima que hasta el
40% del personal sanitario huyó de
Afganistán generando también una escasez
fuerte de personal dentro del país
sumado también al hecho de que el nuevo
gobierno islamista pues no permite a las
mujeres acceder a este tipo de trabajos
y a que otros no están cobrando sus
salarios debido a que no están
recibiendo las ayudas internacionales
con las que se sostiene el país otro
hecho grave es el 90% de las familias
afganas padecen inseguridad alimentaria
la OMS alerta de que uno de cada dos
menores padece desnutrición y los
hospitales están copando con este tipo
de problemas constantemente en cuanto a
la vacunación del covid las cifras de
contagios son inexistentes ante la falta
de testeo pero solo 8,9 millones de
afganos han recibido la vacuna eso es
Raúl menos del 25% de la población otra
enfermedad que es endémica dentro del
país es el sarampión que está sufriendo
ahora un nuevo brote solo en el primer
trimestre del año murieron 150 personas
y más de 18.000 contagios Afganistán
también sigue siendo uno de los países
donde la poliomielitis es endémica y se
está acompañando perdón de una fuerte
tasa de vacunación pues sigue siendo
como escasa claro Marina le preguntó
Cuál es la situación para las mujeres y
que piden además los organismos
humanitarios la emergencia sanitaria
Raúl se agrava más contra las mujeres y
los menores Esto es lo que nos decía
también la Organización Mundial de la
Salud según un informe también de Human
right watch las mujeres sufren una falta
de acceso a la salud sexual reproductiva
el acceso a métodos anticonceptivos
atención postnatal tratamientos de
enfermedades sexuales o mamografías
porque no hay instalaciones adecuadas
para ella también con sus derechos y su
movilidad diezmada porque las mujeres
necesitan estar acompañadas de un hombre
para ceder a la calle Al espacio público
pues no están accediendo a los centros
médicos hospitalarios Esto es lo que
dijo la OMS al respecto
nuestra principal preocupación Es la
falta de acceso a la atención médica
para millones de personas en Afganistán
incluidos niños a los que les faltan las
vacunas esenciales mujeres que no pueden
encontrar atención materna y personas
con condiciones de salud agudas que no
pueden recibir atención oportuna Marina
como siempre Gracias por toda la
información mañana con más salud pasamos
a saludar a nuestra segunda invitada al
día